We need new heroes one
suited for the times we're in
the six episode event has arrived on
disney plus and it's an action-packed epic
people need something to get behind and we're
gonna do it our own way it's a pulse-pounding
experience that will leave you breathless the only
power i have is that i believe we can do better
The last time we see sam and bucky is after
steve leaves the shield with sam sam is coming
to terms with what it's going to be to pick up
that shield and that's where we kick off the
show the legacy of that shield is complicated
when disney plus was announced there was an
opportunity to interweave the cinematic
universe with a television university
the world of the falcon winter soldier
in the films is so big and you want this
show to feel as big and as engrossing i think
fans will definitely get a kick out of seeing
the continuation of that kind of filmmaking that
those movies had sam this has to be subtle got it
the action side is so embedded in what the mcu
is but through the show we wanted to look at the
human side of the characters for bucky it's
the legacy of the winter soldier his anchor
point to the person who knew him before
he was a murder machine no longer exists
so bucky feels unmoored in the series and is
looking for his purpose and sam wilson is very
much doing the same thing when steve first told
me about the shield the first words i said were
feels like it's someone else's i felt like
we would be dishonest just on a human level
if we had this black man just accept the
symbol without having real ambivalence
about it with this series we've been able to
give a level of sincerity and humanity to him
you get a real sense of what this character sam
wilson really is the notion of what blackness
means in america ties very much into sam's journey
through the events of the show there's a fight out
there and then there's our fight here and
bro you have taken them both on get to work
the scope of these six episodes is
really amazing i mean it's a huge story
falcon and winter soldiers are really
vibrant and electric characters so when you
are thrust into the action you sink into the
narrative and where the story ultimately goes
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
falcon and winter soldier episode 3 trailer video
we'll talk all about what's going on with baron
zemo the super soldier serum there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs so if you're brand new to the
channel i'm doing videos for all the episodes
be sure to subscribe to get everything we're
doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships too
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just post all your theories about what you
think is happening in the comments but careful
for spoilers for everything that's happened on
falcon and winter soldiers so far if you haven't
seen it also talk a little bit about wandavision
stuff and obviously stuff from the marvel movies
but where we pick up in episode three falcon and
winter soldier are on their way to baron zemo's
prison back in germany to learn more about the
hydra angle and all this as it relates to
the flag smashers in the super soldiers
because at this point they're kind of mistakenly
thinking that the flag smashers are literally
hydra but just in a different form like when the
nazis fled europe after world war ii and went to
argentina to avoid being arrested for war crimes
buggies kind of jumped to that conclusion because
of their conversation with elijah bradley in their
history fighting each other during the korean war
like when bucky was still hydra because all those
years hydra as well as the us military were trying
to replicate the super soldier serum i'll get into
that in a second because per elijah bradley both
the us and hydra were doing super shady stuff
with the super soldier programs all those years
it all started after captain america went in the
ice and red skull was teleported to vormir by the
tesseract i know everyone's hoping for some red
skull easter eggs during this just because so
much of the series draws from the captain america
character in the movies but they have that funny
scene where falcon is making fun of bucky's cyborg
brain like gears turn in their malfunctioning what
bucky is thinking in this moment after discovering
the eight new super soldiers is the flag smashers
is instantly he's thinking of the hydra super
soldiers that were his teammates in those
captain america civil war flashbacks and he's just
thinking that hydra somehow found a way to create
more super soldier serum since the 90s when the
flashback was taking place winter soldier killed
howard stark iron man's father in the early 90s
while on a mission to steal the samples of super
soldier serum that he had produced it's not meant
to be the same version of the serum that steve
rogers red skull and bucky all got back during
world war ii so if it wasn't clear howard stark
was also part of thunderbolt ross's weapons plus
program just back in the 90s you have to remember
that young howard stark was on the original super
soldier serum team he was working with erskine to
create the first version of captain america
so of course howard stark himself would also
still be working on the program many years later
but getting back to the hydra super soldiers if
it wasn't clear they got rid of all those hydro
super soldiers back during civil war baron zemo
basically just turned off all their life support
systems in the cryo tanks killing the rest of
them before iron man captain america and winter
soldiers showed up at the base the big twist of
that moment during his big villain monologue was
that he hated the idea of super soldiers running
around like he had no plans to unleash them on the
world what oh you think that i'm going to use them
no i killed them a long time ago like zemo says
during the other trailer footage we've already
seen superheroes should not be allowed to exist so
he also considers those to be the super soldiers
that are running around he hates the idea of them
but the reason why bucky wants to get help from
zemo now in present day as he says in the episode
is because zemo knows all of hydra's secrets
i think some people were confused by the line at
the end of the episode where he refers to zemo
as his people he's talking about zemo and hydra
in the same breath because zemo isn't literally
hydra it's just because he's a hydra encyclopedia
zemo learned all their secrets when he was trying
to gather information as part of his plot to
use winter soldier to help break up the avengers
so because they're hyping up the idea that
the power brokers in their organization
are behind the super soldier serum that the flag
smashers got the way they became super soldiers
and zemo hates super soldiers i think we can cross
zemo off the list of people who might secretly be
behind the power broker and if it wasn't clear
the way they're using the name the power broker
is a person but also the name of an organization
on the series that's the way it is in the comics
like it's no one person but there is an actual
character that's referred to as the power broker
it's the same thing they're doing with the
flag smasher name so aaron kellyman's character
carly is a version of the flag smasher character
from the comics but they're also using the name
is the name of their entire organization they're
doing the same thing with the power broker name
and if power broker inc is connected to the super
soldier serum in thunderbolt ross is behind the
weapons plus version of the super soldier serum
there could be some tangential relationship
between the power brokers and thunderbolt ross
in the u.s military we just haven't seen the us
military weapons plus side of that yet we've only
been seeing the flag smashers power broker side
of that so far that doesn't mean that thunderbolt
ross is the power broker or he's behind the power
brokers it just means that he might have some
ties to that organization then in the trailer
we see winter soldier helping falcon train at his
home you see him meeting falcon's family just some
funny moments the special tech case that he has
there might just be a version of his wings and
armor maybe a new version of red wing it's still
not clear in all this other footage when he gets
the shield back from us asian captain america i
still think it's just one shield like you see the
other footage of us agent captain america with it
here in the warehouse then you see falcon throwing
it in a separate scene in the same warehouse with
flag smasher or with carly's character kicking the
shield but it's not clear where all this footage
of him training with it at his home takes place
because clearly it seems like it's after all this
stuff like at some point he either takes it back
from new captain america or the new cap gives
it to him and given the way they left things
at the end of episode 2 they don't seem like
they're going to be best buds anytime soon but
at some point somehow he gets the shield back
and it seems like before they head to madrapore
they have some sort of agreement with the us
military that allows them to continue pursuing
the flag smashers on their own like they say we're
gonna do it our own way that's another reference
to the conversation that they have with a new
cap at the end of episode two about how they're
not bound by military protocols of engagement the
way that he is not that i think that's going to
stop the new dark version of captain america
like military protocols rules of engagement
who cares about that i cannot wait to watch him go
completely off the rails there's also this footage
of an explosion inside what looks like a lab with
biohazard symbols on some of these containers so
this probably has something to do with the power
broker flag smashers plot but this funeral scene
is of the flag smashers burying one of their own
maybe it's the teammate who sacrificed himself in
episode two so they could get away or maybe it's
another one of their teammates who dies later
there are way more of them here too so it seems
like it's one of those communities that they're
delivering quote-unquote supplies to i'm also
hoping they start to tease more of the weapons
plus thunderball ross storyline with u.s agents
captain america like it seems as if he keeps
getting one-upped by the flag smashers like he got
his ass kicked by a little girl like they made the
joke about winter soldier you got your ass kicked
by that little girl the same thing happened to
that angry new captain america so for all tying
this back to super soldier program weapons plus
you remember what happened during the incredible
hulk movie when the abomination tried to capture
the hook at the very beginning of the film he
got his ass handed to him immediately so that's
when thunderbolt ross came in like hold my beer
i've got a little something that might be able
to help you out he dusts off the latest iteration
of his super soldier serum that they replicated
in the tank here reads weapons plus but the reason
why the name on here is dr reinstein is because
reinstein was dr erskine's real name during that
first captain america movie erskine was just the
pseudonym he was using when he decided to defect
to the united states and you notice that the batch
number on this tank reads batch six version two so
it means it's the sixth iteration of the weapons
plus program each new test subject becomes a new
number like steve rogers is designation weapon one
wolverine is designation weapon ten the x in
weapon x stands for roman numeral ten so i guess
that means that the abomination is the mcu weapon
6. in more hulk easter eggs like they referenced
the hulk at the beginning of episode 2 hulk's
gamma experiments that wound up turning him into
the hulk were all part of the weapons plus program
remember in that first captain america movie when
they bombard his body with vitarase after they
dosed him with the super soldier serum in order
to activate the serum in his body like get it to
actually do the work of enhancing him in present
day thunderbolt ross was trying to get the hulk
to do something similar but using gamma rays to
bombard people's bodies thunderbolt ross even says
well you know maybe it seemed like something went
wrong or maybe maybe something went very right
one of my other favorite lines of dialogue from
him in that movie is when he says i consider that
man's entire body property of the us military like
he considers the hulk literally is property of
the us military later in that movie abomination
also has the leader character who also still alive
in the mcu could always potentially come back he
has him bombard him with gamma rays after dosing
him with more of the hulk's gamma-infused blood
and that's what upgrades him to full-blown comic
book abomination so it's always possible that dark
captain america here eventually has the weapons
plus program give him a version of the super
soldier serum so that he can match these other
flag smashers super soldiers i'm also kind of
hoping that that puts him on track for potential
thunderbolts return like i don't think they're
going to kill his character off or anything like
that anybody who doesn't wind up dying in the mcu
is always potential to come back in the future
but it's pretty clear that falcon is going to get
the shield and become the new version of captain
america eventually so then what happens to this
new dark version of captain america if they
wind up taking the name from him early theory
he goes super dark takes the us agent name or
a slightly different comic book name and then
winds up potentially coming back during a future
thunderbolts project but everyone let me know in
the comments do you think that they're going
to give the new dark captain america a similar
abomination style storyline where eventually
they do dose him up with a version of the super
soldier serum as far as falcon goes i don't think
that he's going to wind up getting the serum it's
always possible but i think the idea especially
in all the dialogue that he has in these trailers
is where he says i don't have special powers my
special power is the belief that we can do better
in the same way that iron man doesn't have special
powers or enhancements he just has his technology
to put him on the level of the other avengers
heroes i'll do a couple more bonus videos for
falcon and winter soldier this week but leave
all your video requests in the comments below
there's a couple really big things coming out soon
everyone click here for my full falcon and winter
soldier episode 2 video in easter eggs and click
here for my brand new suicide squad trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!